[Music]  new at six the i-team confirming the  secretary of state's office is now  investigating nearly two dozen cases of  potential  voter fraud stemming from last year's  election last month the nevada  republican party delivered four boxes  worth of  allegations of fraud out of nearly 4 000  names a review from the office of vital  statistics  found 10 voters were dead in november  had ballots cast in their names  the review also found 10 other people  may have voted twice the secretary of  state's office maintains that number is  well below initial allegations of more  than a hundred thousand people voting  illegally  several judges including the state  supreme court threw out lawsuits to  overturn those election results